hello and welcome to M coding I'm James
Murphy let's get going talking about
descriptors contrary to how the name
might sound descriptors are not the
mutual enemy of Autobots and Decepticons
nor do they have anything to do with
descriptions descriptors in Python are
somewhat of a feature that's hidden in
plain sight
officially an object is a descriptor if
it has any of these Dunder get set or
delete methods
and their purpose is to allow you to
customize what it means to get set or
delete an attribute
in this case X is an instance of the
descriptor on the left
when you call object.x this calls the
descriptor's get method when you call
object.x equals something that calls the
set method and when you call Del
object.x that calls the delete
yet takes the object and the object type
importantly this allows you to do
different things based off of whether
something was called from an instance or
the class itself
if this is your first time hearing about
descriptors in Python you're probably
thinking this is one of those very Niche
features it's Advanced use only and oh
by the way isn't that the same thing as
get Adder set adder and Dell Adder why
is there a need for descriptors at all
it is true that without knowing more
about the internals of your class
something.x could be calling the get
adder or it could be calling the get
method of a descriptor object.x equals
something could be calling the set adder
or it could be calling a set of a
descriptor and Dell object.x could be
calling a Dell adder or a delete of a
descriptor without seeing the internals
of the class you just can't tell but
there's a big difference between get
Adder set adder and Dell Adder versus
the descriptor versions namely the
methods on the right hand side are
defined per class whereas the ones on
the left hand side are defined per
attribute on the right it's the class
that's determining how to access
attributes whereas on the left it's the
attribute itself that determines how
it's accessed even still you may be
thinking descriptors I'm never going to
need that right I never Define
descriptors I never work with
descriptors I don't need to know well
welcome to my list of descriptors hiding
in plain sight you may not have realized
it but you're using them all the time in
descriptor number one functions have you
ever noticed a difference that you get
when you access a function through an
instance versus through the class
accessing the function f through an
instance little a we get a bound method
but accessing the same F through the
class itself gives us a function object
it's the same F in both cases but I'm
getting different results
that's because every function you define
with the def keyword is a descriptor
that defines a get method and it uses
the descriptor protocol to do something
different based off of whether it was
called from an instance or the class
itself functions in Python are written
in C so this isn't exactly what it's
doing but it's something close to this
every function has a get method if the
object is non then there's no instance
Associated to this lookup meaning it was
called from a class object itself in
that case we just return the function as
is
otherwise object isn't none and we're in
a case like this where we're looking up
a function on an actual instance
variable and in that case instead of
returning the function itself we return
some kind of bound function that
remembers the object
so yeah if you're using functions then
you're using descriptors number two
descriptor hidden in plain sight
properties
and yes this is a different case than
just functions let me show you why let's
reach into the classes dictionary and
print out what this area thing actually
is I'm accessing it through the
dictionary like this in order to avoid
invoking the descriptor we see that area
is not actually a function it's a
property object
first area is defined as a function just
like normal then you replace area with
whatever you get by calling property on
it that's why technically area is a
property object not a function so this
is exactly the same as this
and property is a descriptor so it
controls what it does when you say dot
area it just so happens that what it
does is call that original area function
properties like this are never really
needed you could always just call the
function directly but it's a common way
to indicate to the programmer that this
thing is really cheap to compute by
making area a property you're basically
telling users that area is so cheap to
compute that it's basically as free as
an attribute access if for some reason
your area function really was expensive
then make it look expensive don't hide
the fact that it's a function call just
make That explicit funnily enough the
main reason that I see people use
properties is actually to introduce a
feature to python that was specifically
left out of The Language by Design in
Python all attributes are public there's
no way to prevent someone from accessing
internal implementation details of your
classes and aside from inheriting from a
built-in type like Tuple this also makes
it impossible to make truly immutable
types but this is a pretty common
pattern to prevent people from
accidentally mutating your object add an
underscore to the beginning of your
attribute name then make a property with
the same name without the underscore
people can still read the name no
problem
but if they try to write to it they get
an error but of course this isn't true
immutability someone could just reach
inside and manually change the
underscore variable name but it's pretty
much an unspoken rule in Python that if
you have an underscore variable or
underscore function then you're not
meant to touch those
so if you do change an underscore
variable or call it underscore function
then you should expect everything to
break it's your own fault anyway here's
how you might Implement property if you
were doing it yourself the built-in
property also does set and delete but
you get the idea as per usual if you
weren't past an instance then just
return the property itself otherwise
call the stored function on the instance
that was passed in
hidden descriptor number three class
methods and static methods both class
and static methods allow you to call a
function whether you have an instance of
the class or the class itself in both
cases since you might not have an
instance to work with there's no self
parameter and the difference is that a
static method has no implied parameters
whereas a class method has an implied
class parameter so in both of these
cases whether you called with the
capital animal class or the lowercase
animal instance the class parameter of
the create function will be filled in
with the animal class I have a whole
video on class methods versus static
methods check that out if you want to
hear more as far as possible
implementations go they could look
something like this just like properties
both of these take and remember the
function that they're applied to static
method is much simpler whether you were
called with an instance or not just
always return the function back last
method is a bit trickier because we need
to supply that class parameter if we
weren't past the type to use then we
just use the type of the object then
this is how we bind that object to the
class parameter remember functions are
descriptors and the get method returns a
bound version of the function where the
first argument is bound to the first
argument of the get it's not totally
clear if the second argument matters at
all but this works so as you can see
descriptors are often used to make sort
of function object like things but
that's not all they're useful for let's
take a look at number four slots this is
another one that I have a full video on
but here's the quick rundown
normally objects have an instance
dictionary
anytime you store a variable into the
object it really just stores it inside
this dictionary but especially for small
objects dictionaries aren't necessarily
the most efficient way to store things
if you define slots equals XYZ then
you're saying the only three attributes
that my instances are going to have are
X Y and Z you can get set and delete X Y
and Z no problem but if you try to get
set or delete W then you get an error
once again directly reaching inside the
classes dictionary we see that X is a
member object these slots members also
Define all three of get set and delete
and because there's no instance
dictionary to manage this these get set
and delete have to reach into the
underlying C structure of the objects
and manually modify them again see my
video on slots if you'd like to hear
more
and speaking of instance dictionaries do
you know what else are descriptors
instance dictionaries
the dunder [ __ ] attribute of any class
that has instant dictionaries isn't a
dictionary it's an attribute object
which is a descriptor with all three of
get set and delete and notice this weird
idiom that I had to do in order to see
this attribute object I had to reach
into the dictionary of the class and
then read the dictionary if you print
out just the dict it looks like a
dictionary
but if you look at the type you see that
it's actually a mapping proxy object
this happens because remember dict is a
descriptor so accessing e dot dunderdict
invokes the descriptor and what the
descriptor does is return this proxy
object instead of the actual attribute
so that's why we had to do this doubled
underdict thing moving on how about a
real world Library use case of
descriptors look no further than one of
the most popular python packages of all
time SQL Alchemy SQL Alchemy lets you
communicate with databases through
python in a pythonic way
here I Define a user account table with
two Fields ID and name
when I Define the class I say that ID is
a column that takes integers and name is
a column that takes strings when I
operate on an actual instance of the
class I'm working not with column
objects but with actual ins and strings
getting different behavior on a class
versus an instance you guessed it
they're descriptors number seven another
common use for descriptors is field
validation
for example I want to say here this item
has a price that's greater than zero
whenever I set a price I want to make
sure that it's positive and if not I
want an error this functionality is
accomplished in the set method before
setting the attribute check if it's
bigger than zero otherwise throw a value
error then proceed with setting the
attribute this is an interesting use
case for Python's under set name this
function is called a class construction
time and its purpose is to let each
object know what its name is after the
class body runs this greater than object
will be told that its name is price by
having the set name called with the
owner being the item class and the name
being price in this case I'll prepend an
underscore to the name and then use that
as the sort of private location where
I'm storing the actual data so the
descriptor is stored at dot price but
the value that's underlying the price
the actual price gets stored at dot
underscore price knowing the name that
we're assigned to is a good way to avoid
conflicts if you have multiple of these
descriptors in the same class so if I
also had a quantity field then there
wouldn't be any fight over where to
store each of them they each have their
own private location and the final
descriptor on my list is super lookups
suppose I have a package class that can
ship to some address
and an Express package that ships faster
I don't really recommend doing this but
you can set a base view onto your class
create a super object and stick it on
there if you ship an Express package
it's on the way right away but if you
call ship on the base view then you'll
get the parents behavior I'm not going
to go into why this works here I have a
whole video on super if you want to see
the Gory details
this next portion is slightly more
advanced and deals with some tricky
issues you might run into so if a
descriptor's get method and a classes
get Adder method can both Define what it
means to say object dot something then
what happens if you have a class that
has both I encourage you to take this
example and try commenting and
uncommenting things to see how things
actually work
the first trip up is that there's not
just one get Adder there's get adder and
get attribute and get attribute is
actually the one that's more similar to
set adder and Dell adder get attribute
set adder and Dell Adder are all always
called when you say object dot something
get attribute is always called when you
say object dot something equals set
Adder is always called when you say Del
object dot something Del Adder is always
called and for these three functions
it's actually the base object class
whose versions of those functions
actually implement the descriptor logic
so if you're defining that attribute set
adder or Del Adder then you should call
the base objects version of that
function inside your implementation if
you want it to work with descriptors if
you don't call the base objects version
you'll find that your descriptor methods
get set delete are not called unless of
course you manually call them in your
version of the function that's to say
you can sort of override the descriptor
protocol if you so choose and then
there's get Adder which is actually only
called if get attribute raises an
attribute error so how does get
attribute decide what order to do things
in the object version of get attribute
has a series of fallbacks that it tries
to figure out which one is the best one
to call if it finds a descriptor that
has a get and a set or delete then
that's called a data descriptor and it
has the highest priority next it checks
inside the instance dictionary then it
checks for descriptors that just have a
get these are called non-data
descriptors then it checks for variables
found at the class level then it'll
raise an attribute error which triggers
the to get Adder if it exists these
defaults are definitely not obvious
although they are generally good for
most use cases it may feel especially
weird that instance variables are split
between these data versus non-data
descriptors
the reason that non-data descriptors get
lower priority than instance variables
is because the most common use case for
these is caching the descriptor computes
some expensive variable and then saves
it in the instance dictionary the next
time it gets looked up it's found in the
instance dictionary and isn't recomputed
this was chosen because of how common
caching is but if you want your
descriptor to always be preferred then
you can just Define a set or delete that
just does the default thing here's a
case where you can see that priority
difference play out for X I have a data
descriptor it defines both a get and a
set whereas y just has a get both of our
gets return none so when we print X and
Y we get none then for both X and Y we
store 42 in the instance dictionary
print them out again and for X we get
none but for y we get 42 this is because
the data descriptors get which returns
none has a higher priority than the dict
whereas the non-data descriptors get is
not called because the dictionary has
higher priority in that case obviously
the rules are complex non-intuitive and
I don't expect you to get them in one go
I just hope this helps you remember that
there is some subtlety there and you
might want to look into it if you're
ever defining a descriptor like this
anyway thanks for making it to the end I
hope you enjoyed it as always thank you
to my patrons and donors for supporting
me if you enjoy my content please
consider subscribing and if you
especially enjoy please consider
becoming a patron on patreon don't
forget to slap that like button an odd
number of times see you next time